[Musique]
le bazar bazar est une association qui
propose un événement festif et solidaire
tous les ans depuis 2016
on a un comme un festival chaque année
au mois de février pour lutter contre le
cancer
[Musique]
il va y avoir des concerts des
interviews sérieuse et puis des
spectacles donc avec la compagnie du
contraire
l'artiste julio do nascimento qui lui à
venir faire les arts du cirque de la
danse avec la compagnie the dance dons
en ligne sur et les oiseaux on a une
page donc on peut donner directement là
vous tapez lots assaut sur notre site
internet on a un lien directement bazar
bizarre point com et aussi nous avons un
partenariat avec des commerçants de
conflent et de d'andrésy où on a des
boîtes à dons